Wow
what a beautiful day listen everyone
cheering this is gonna be great
months of training is paying off now I'm
hydrated glucose stuck and my mental
game is on point let's do this
okay so I'm a little behind on my normal
pace no big deal just keep going and I
think I missed a spot on my thigh with
my body glide sure that won't be a
problem and I don't need to stop for
water just yet whoa look here comes some
hills that'll be fun
wait I'm not even halfway through yet
feels like I've been running forever
what's with all these hills the whole
course hills I think it's gonna be
tougher than I thought where is
everybody
am I still on course I haven't seen a
water stop in forever why didn't I get
water earlier let's just meet myself
with a road I guess nothing left to do
besides confront all of my inner demons
I am going to die
why did I ever decide to do this my
thighs are raw like two hams and I think
my toenails just fell off what else
could possibly go wrong like the runners
trucks well at least I haven't hit the
wall yet I hit the wall I've never been
so tired at all my life even my teeth
are tired I I think I should just quit
to stop maxing me you jugs
[Music]
No I need to power through I didn't
train for months to give up this late
time to dig deep think of that Olympic
runner who finished with a broken leg
that was really gross but the point is
if he can do it so can I now come on the
finish line is right up there one foot
in front of the other I did it oh this
is the greatest feeling in the world
carry me to the car I am going to eat my
weight in pasta it's a new profession
[Music]